ah
just
right
[Music]
this is the real me ah
don't you think it's time things were
different
hello
i'm willing to go further than anyone
[Music]
do i have your attention
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome and thank you
for joining us on our live chat with
prime video scientists my name is tammy
ludwig and i'm going to be your
moderator today um thank you so much for
taking the time out of your day to be
with us on twitch please remember that
we regularly host these events so
you can follow up with us on our
notification page for future events
we also received a lot of great
questions from everyone so thank you
again for submitting those uh we're
going to be taking the questions during
the event as well so please feel free to
post your questions in the chat on
twitch and once we get through our
pre-submitted questions we'll go to
those live questions as well
with that said i'd like to introduce you
to all of our speakers today uh we have
ali karen rafae and youngjun
each of them are going to tell us a
little bit more about who they are what
they do in prime video what excites them
the most about the future of prime video
and a fun fact uh ali why don't you kick
us off
sure thanks uh my name is uh alexandias
i'm an apply science manager in prime
video personalization team
i joined amazon around
six years ago after my postdoc at
columbia university
my team comprised of scientists who work
on a diverse set of problems such as
customer item relevance
item item relevance and page composition
and what i'm excited about the future of
prime video is that
we
are building models
that scale
worldwide and serve diversity of users
from across the globe
and that's a really big challenge that
i'm really excited about
the fun fact um is that i'm really
exhausted right now
as i have a two months old that doesn't
sleep much at night so he keeps me awake
but it's all fun it's all good
i love how you're able to say no sleep
is a fun fact
that's awesome um karen
would you mind going next
sure um
hi everyone my name is karen chen and
i'm a senior applied scientist with
prime video
my team built end-to-end system via
computer vision and machine learning to
help customers discover more and
better content that prime video offers
i'm excited for my current job because i
get to apply the state of art technology
to solve real life problems
while working with all the great people
around me that have the same passion
when i'm not working i enjoy hiking with
my family and my dog
as you know seattle has thousands of
beautiful trails so if you like to
explore the nature as me i think seattle
is here to welcome you
i'm the same way karen i'm a huge hiker
and it's a good way to exhaust to the
family as well
especially during covid um rafae would
you mind going next tell us a little bit
more about yourself
sure so hi everyone my name is raf i'm a
principal applied scientist in prime
video
and as a principal scientist i work in
the areas of computer vision and machine
learning
for those of you who don't know
computer vision is about using
algorithms and data to learn models that
can then understand what's going on in
images and video
so
i collaborate with a lot of people
across prime video but
my immediate art that i am sitting in is
called
video compliance and classification so
we use computer vision and machine
learning to build models it can predict
what type of content is going on so that
we can
we can show that content to the right
audience and particularly we
we deal a lot with
sensitive activities age-appropriate
activities to ensure that the trust that
our customers put in us um is maintained
um and so
i'm most excited about priming videos
future because i know that prime video
is super committed to customer impact
and it allows me to use my technical
background uh to make that impact in a
very efficient way and hands-on way and
fun fact uh so i'm i'm in similar board
as ali we've had our second child a
daughter uh
almost five and a half months ago so i'm
i'm sleeping more than and then ali
seems to be sleeping but uh most of my
fun these days is my family with my
family and kids and before kovid era
started i used to play
competitive squash uh seattle is a great
place to play squash
so so yeah if you if you're interested
in squash among other things seattle is
a great place to be
i love that fact um that's i did not
know that about you refae uh and then
ali um you're next please
uh i think we're doing good yeah so oh
i'm sorry youngjun i'm sorry go ahead go
for it sure hi this is
a senior pm playback organization in
prime video i'm working on video
playback and delivery end-to-end from
camera to screen
about both scientific and engineering
efforts
i have been prime video for about five
and a half years
when i joined a prime video there was
only one traditional business and tech
pillar freedom demand at that time prime
video was a fairly small organization as
a whole there were only two principal
engineers in prime video in the past
five years we expanded our business into
live streaming in green both live linear
channels and live events
and then video s in both video demand
and live streaming the past five years
are the fast growing period for prime
video i'm really glad and proud that i'm
part of growth and we are still fast
growing now and in the future in all
dimensions
my fun fact is that engineer thinks i'm
a scientist but scientists think i'm
engineer i'm a mix of both
awesome youngjun thank you for that so
um we are going to jump into our live q
a everybody we're going to start
actually with the pre-submitted
questions so the first question for
everybody uh we would love to know what
are you most proud of that your teams
are driving and what have you created
for your customer that you are most
proud of uh yeongjun why don't you kick
us off here sure like i mentioned in my
short intro i'm most proud that my teams
expanded prime videos business into a
few new areas live streaming including
both live viewing channels and live
events such as epl tnf and mba and the
video ads in both live streaming and
video demand
all the work and projects from my teams
enable more scenarios for customers to
enjoy video experiences from prime video
in the future coming very soon a
multi-exclusive deal of tnf between
national football league in the prime
video we have 30 million concurrent
viewers across tens or thousand device
types there will be lots of new
challenges coming soon which need
expertise in video areas including
computer vision and machine learning
to support seamless video playback
experiences for prime video customers
obviously we need innovative solutions
there
wonderful thank you so much uh rafae
would you mind answering this question
next
sure happy to tell me so yeah building
on essentially what youngjun was saying
right so
i work in the area of computer vision
and machine learning and fundamentally
it's applied to towards the
understanding automatic understanding of
our content and a video understanding is
really a central part of a whole wide
spectrum of the use cases that we are
that we are making for our for our
customers so starting from ingestion all
the way to playback computer vision and
machine learning are a fundamental part
of what we do uh every day for those
for those set of use cases for example
if you if you start with ingestion
looking at at what point should we
insert ads that could be minimally
disruptive to our customers right you
need to know at what point are the sort
of the boundaries of the scene that are
actually changing similarly um you know
as i mentioned before which parts of
content contain um uh
sensitive activities or age-appropriate
activities to which par which part of
the of the video contain
activities that are related to maybe
cardio chasing so that we can show them
to people who like car chases versus not
all the way to live you know how many
bits should we put to which part of the
scene to be able to make make a good
experience for our customers uh so so
that is sort of the type of things that
i uh that i you know
spend my day uh doing and that's the
that's the thing that i'm most excited
about uh to be delivering for our
customers
wonderful like karen would you mind
following up now that would be great
yeah sure uh thank you yonjin and rafee
um i cannot agree with you both anymore
i think from my perspective just to add
on top of that
um i'm very proud of my work because um
i feel like my team is very customer
obsessed
and uh we always work backward from how
to improve
our customers experience with prime
video
for instance
with large number of movies and tv shows
available nowadays it can be very time
consuming for our customer to discover
the content that best meet their needs
in order to solve this pinpoint
we generate short form previews ranging
from 30 seconds to one minute long
and the featuring various aspects of a
movie and a tv show
such as
different characters genres mood and
storyline and we then auto play this
previews so that we can help customers
to make a faster and more informed
choice on what to stream
so um so to put in short i think i'm
very proud that i get to see the actual
impact of my work on customer
satisfaction and engagement with prime
video
great thank you karen and then finally
ali um if you could let us know that
would be great
sure um so in the space of uh
personalization we um
technically uh historically we've been
using a lot of customer behavior to to
drive our recommendations
um so lots of collaborative filtering
algorithms if you guys are familiar with
um
so um in our space uh we've we've seen
that more and more uh we need to take in
more signals such as like the title
uh metadata title um the the content of
the title and and we really uh i'm very
proud of like the way that we our team
is using them uh very
in great ways so that we can serve our
customers better we can find better
content for the user and
show more relevant
titles for our users
great thank you everybody i really
appreciate your thoughtful responses to
that first question um let's go to the
second uh
pre-submitted question uh this is an
interesting one what is one of the
biggest challenges your teams are
currently facing um alia would you
actually mind kicking us off here
sure
um so one of the
biggest challenges that we have in the
space of recommender systems
is
the topic of parity and fairness for for
all users so uh this is especially um
pronounced uh
these days in in in the form of di uh
diversity equity and inclusion and uh
the fact is that like we serve a huge
variety of users in every marketplace
over and across the globe uh the people
with different backgrounds different
tastes and making sure that our
algorithms are not biased by the
majority of people this is a huge
challenge that we are facing not only uh
in prime video but across uh in in
in in the recommender systems and uh as
we are this uh as we are serving a
global
users we do need to uh take this uh
issue very seriously and uh and we're
working on it
as a matter of fact
i would say that that is probably the
probably largest problems that we face
in this case
great thank you
um youngjun same question for you what
is one of the biggest challenges your
team is currently facing sure uh to me
crime will have more and more contents
serving more and more customers through
limited capacity of internet
infrastructure as we all know that prime
video have more than 175 million
customers right now uh how can we make
good videos smaller and smaller videos
look better it's always one the biggest
challenge in prime video we have to
utilize computer vision and machine
learning algorithm to spend each bit at
the right place and provide a lot of
visual quality from tens of thousands
device types for customers and any
location in the world and any time of
course we've seen these video played by
experiences
wonderful young june i love that we're
getting more content so i really
appreciate your team working on all of
that visual quality um reface what same
question for you please
yeah absolutely and building on what
john john is mentioning you know we are
getting more content
which is great
and at the same time the diversity of
topics that we are getting in this
content is also very high the places in
which these this content is being filmed
is is getting more and more varied so
essentially what that effect what is
what the effect that that is happening
on
on computer vision algorithms from that
perspective is that we need more and
more training labels to be able to train
more accurate uh models so that we can
predict when we see
you know a scene or a shot and so
the biggest technical challenge when i
speak purely technically is the
acquisition of these labels and you know
acquiring these labels is part of it
quality assurance of these labels is
another part of it there is a whole life
cycle associated to these labels right
so um
given the scale at which we operate um
it is really important for us to come up
with
the techniques that
enable us to build statistical models
that are not so label hungry so we've
been working actively in that area and
in fact uh
one of our most recent pieces of work in
that area that uses this thing called
self-supervised learning uh which is
much more label efficient way to learn
uh models uh
we just recently published it in cbpr
2021 and essentially is for the
downstream task of scene boundary
detection when does a scene change from
one scene to another scene and in fact
uh so that's one example of how we're
using cutting edge technology to
overcome that label acquisition and
maintenance challenge and i think we
have a a video
set of results for this
for this work that we'd like to show to
our audience and
just to set it up these are some example
scenarios uh of different types of
scenes that are changing from one scene
to another that our algorithm was able
to to detect correctly just to give you
a sense of what this type of work is all
about so with that in mind let's let's
play the video please
stop a grenade in that pool let's move
back out
street's clear
nah
but i know she was having trouble with
them
hey norah you got a minute sure honey
what's up i was wondering if you know of
any other cleaning gigs what about that
house you got it's getting weird there
so the jungle juice is just about
started
[Music]
[Music]
he's just expressing his opinion no i
exactly
[Music]
thank you so much for sharing that video
with us rafee it makes me excited to be
part of prime video right now and what
we're doing um karen if you wouldn't
mind i would love for you to answer that
same question what is one of the biggest
challenges your team is currently facing
sure um and also yeah thank you rafe for
the video um this is very engaging um
talking about engaging uh it it reminds
me one of the biggest challenges that
our team is facing
um as i mentioned earlier our team
continuously generate engaging short
form previews so that we can use it to
promote a movie or tv show
however the definition of engaging can
be vague and it can be hard
on the one hand engaging can be widely
different depending on the content
itself
like
a motion movie versus sports versus
documentary
they can all have very different
engaging scenes as defined
on the other hand depending on who the
customer is
one video can mean very engaging but the
other customer may think it's not
interesting at all
um like take me as example um
if like um if i was um auto play i was
shown
like a preview of movie mission
impossible
it will convince me to watch this movie
when the short film previews
is featuring my favorite actor of tom
cruise
in it
versus my friend may care more about
scenes just highlighting
actions such as cartesian or explosions
so this
all this diversity and the variations in
defining engaging is a continuing and
challenging for our team and
we are
adopting
a different
technology and try to generate more and
more engaging and short form previews to
help our customer to
discover the new content
wonderful karen thank you so much for
that
um up next uh this is a great question
as well i would love to get everybody's
thoughts around this one as a scientist
in prime video what are the day-to-day
projects and problems you would work on
we understand content delivery is an
aspect but would love for you to go
deeper into other parts uh rafae would
you mind kicking off this question for
us
sure happy to tell me so
uh let's see i
i think that i as a principal scientist
has spent a lot of my time on on on the
technical
side of the of the story uh everything
from modeling to to training
deployment maintenance all those good
things
but
at the same time a large part of my days
are also spent on um
thinking about and brainstorming on new
initiatives what are the strategic
initiatives that p that prime video we
call it pv uh inside of prime video uh
we
you know we invest in uh working with my
peers my seniors to to figure that part
out um also i spent a good amount of my
time in
um in
hiring uh you know
more talent which we need in computer
vision machine learning because those
are my expertise uh so help
the organization out from that
perspective and and something that is
very dear and near to me which is
mentorship uh you know once we have um
hired somebody how do we advise them uh
to to deliver uh at their best possible
level and also you know uh go through
the growth that we uh
you know uh like we want to go through
uh at amazon so those are some of the
big buckets that i would bin my
day-to-day time in uh
yeah
wonderful that's great um yongjun would
you mind taking this question next
sure thanks murphy for the introduction
of his day-to-day work for me i'm
working on video playback delivery
end-to-end from camera to screen i can
apply my expertise and experiences in my
daily work all the time are interesting
scientific and engineering target
topics from different projects that
require deep dives and analysis in math
or require comprehensive multimedia
backgrounds
solutions to challenging topics and
projects from playback delivery provide
opportunities for me to educate and grow
other engineers across amazon as well
as senior pe i'm working on both
horizontally across multiple
organizations to drive overlapping
initiatives and projects and vertically
on sony and long penny issues with
individual engineers successfully
delivering impactful results to
customers
when there are
questions on ambiguous topics i wrote
tutorials that help grow expertise of
other engineers and help them work
independently on similar topics i'm also
leading the interstellar research
program arising from challenging topics
in prime video collaborating with
universities and professors for example
we have multi-year research contract
between ut austin and the prime video
about video quality evaluation and
prediction in live sports all based on
computer vision and machine learning
my day-to-day work is shifting among
those interesting initiatives and
challenges coming from all dimensions
wonderful young june thank you so much
for that
uh karen same question for you what are
the day-to-day projects and problems um
you're working on
sure um
yeah i think um echo uh what youngjin
has and that rafe has just talked about
and uh for me
my day-to-day activity also changes over
time
um i remember when i first joined my
team it was a small a relatively small
organization and with limited scope
so
at that time my main focus is to build
um machine learning models so that we
can promote the movie and the tv shows
that are produced by amazon studios
so that was then
later on as our team expand my
day-to-day work also expand accordingly
that we start to include computer vision
in my day-to-day work because we need to
enlarge the infantry of the short form
previews
that we can cover all of the movie and
the tv that the entire prime video
catalog offers
so by then my work actually is more
balanced between computer vision and
machine learning
and
in addition
in addition to daily model building work
i'm also involved heavily in science
vision and product roadmap discussion
because this is the time when
i collaborate very closely with our
product leadership with our engineering
team and we get to work and i think and
a dream big together
wonderful karen thank you and then ollie
same question for you
um
sure so as a as a science manager uh in
prime video one of the things that i do
very regularly is
uh reaching out across amazon um and we
have a very diverse set of teams at
amazon as you know from retail
amazon.com to books to
kindle
music
twitch
so we have a lot of
efforts going on in personalization so
one of the things that i do is reaching
out across
teams to learn about these efforts and
um and
kind of cross-pollinate if you like uh
between these teams and and bring the
learning to
to my team and share the learnings from
our team with others that's one of the
great things actually that i found about
prime video
that that enables us to to scale
more than the number of people that we
have
wonderful ollie thank you for that
all right folks let's jump to the next
question um what keeps you motivated in
your role and just working with prime
video in general uh young june could you
take this one first please
sure as a senior principal engineer i
have the opportunity to set a technical
vision try broad and impactful
initiatives and dive deep into long
pending issues
given the growth of prime video and
other multimedia related organizations
in amazon there are always interesting
challenges to be solved moreover i can
see my ideas turning shoes from math
equation on the paper to source codes
and then customer facing features they
write in video playback that gives me a
sense of success and satisfication
on the other hand i'm always active
educator for junior engineers
really interested in the growth of next
generation tech experts with my
tutorials and educational talk i'm glad
to see the success of young generational
engineers in amazon through my education
that makes me feel really great
wonderful rafae um if you wouldn't mind
the same question please
yeah absolutely so i i i share a lot of
the sentiment that and that was uh uh
mentioned by yong joon um i think uh uh
you know there are two big parts of it
that keeps me motivated
at least two but
the big ones are
you know
essentially
a
prime video provides me with a very
tight loop
of
coming up with novel solutions to
challenging problems and seeing their
impact uh on the customer i think i
think it's one of the most efficient
ways that i've seen any organization do
in my at least in my career and i've
done a ton of learning ever since i've
joined prime videos so that that
learning and that
that
visibility to the impact really keeps me
motivated and secondly i would say more
from a technical perspective
uh you know we've talked a lot about our
uh you know
sort of very large catalog video catalog
right and also the challenges of of
labels and the cutting edge deep
learning models etc so i think there
there's a we are at a conference of
multiple things like large amounts of
unlabeled data this challenge of having
very large amounts of label data to then
train traditional models and how do we
solve that and so
the the ecosystem both in terms of data
availability and compute availability
that prime video offers me and the
organizations that i
collaborate with that then facilitate us
being able to you know push the push the
envelope in in deep learning machine
learning computer vision etc that is
something from a technological
perspective that i really look forward
to so those those would be you know two
of the top things although there are
many more things that keep me motivated
but those are the top ones
wonderful rafae thank you so much for
that karen i'd love to hear from you on
this one what keeps you motivated in
your role and working within prime video
in general
sure thank you tammy um so for me uh in
addition to what uh my colleagues has
already mentioned um i think a couple of
things motivate me uh one is the
mentorship
actually to talk more abroad it's more
the science community the culture in
amazon that motivate me
so talking about the science community
we have a bunch of
resources so we have the mentorship
program
and
i love the mentorship program because i
can find the mentor that
in specific domain area that very ex
expertise on that and i can learn a lot
from my mentor
and at the same time i can also
contribute to
this science community by being the
mentor for other
scientists so it's it's a two-way um
a program which i feel very helpful to
me
and at the same time
we also have the reading group
in the science community community that
uh we a bunch of scientists will gather
together and we find
some latest paper that we think that we
want to
try and adopt in our real
world problem that's also something that
motivates me because when people sit
together and learn together the sparks
usually come out of it
finally uh we have amazon machine
learning university
that um
not only that we can learn um
all the uh the latest techniques uh from
those six week
intensive courses
we get also can you know be the teacher
and teach at the machine learning
university which is something i did and
enjoy a lot
so that's a bunch of things that
motivate me i love that i just love
hearing about all the growth
opportunities that's awesome karen thank
you so much
um this question this next question is
near and dear from me since i'm in
recruiting um for someone looking to
join your team what skill sets are
required and what advice would you give
to somebody interviewing rafae i would
love for you to kick this one off
sure tammy happy too so i would say that
you know obviously we are looking for
folks who
uh can contribute on a uh on the
technical front so uh at least from a
computer vision machine learning
perspective i can speak that you know uh
folks should prepare uh from a
technological perspective you know happy
be able to dive deep on the problem
be very familiar with the practical
implications of the solutions that they
that they come up with because amazon is
extremely you know practical customer
focused customer obsessed uh company so
those parts are very important but i
wanna
also highlight the importance of
something uh that some of the
technologists you know usually don't
think of when they think about
interviewing and at least at amazon it's
given a lot of importance which is your
your attitude uh towards uh you know
just general problem solving and your
leadership principles and so i would
strongly advise uh and recommend people
who are considering to to interview in
any organization in amazon to really uh
you know have a very humble attitude be
open to uh to be provided feedback be
you know
willing to take feedback in a very
constructive way you know try not to
have any chip on your shoulders etc so i
think your attitude is really going to
take you a long way and one last thing i
want to say is that if if all these
things are difficult to remember some
for somebody i'd give you a very simple
rule of thumb that i have tried to use
in my career and i always try to preach
about it which is uh try to think like a
like a founder i don't don't try to
think like an employee but rather think
like a founder when you when you do that
and you truly do that there will be a
fundamental shift in how you perceive
everything and how you view everything
and then ownership and all the rest of
the good things will come very naturally
um so yeah that that would be some of my
advice to uh
to the folks who are thinking about it
great advice rafe
um youngjun i would love to hear more
about your advice here
uh thanks rafe for all the insightful
suggestions to add on top of that i
would like to emphasize that thinking
process and the mindset are super
important besides existing skill sets
which are also very important of course
i would suggest that candidates should
really take a look on amazon leadership
principles i internalize them i often
see that some candidates have pretty
good background and expertise but didn't
pass next screen of amazon leadership
principles in my organization about
video playback and delivery we need
talents in all the dimensions and areas
of video streaming compression
networking video processing computer
vision and machine learning so don't
worry we are openings in all different
areas we are always welcome to apply
wonderful thank you
and then ali same question for you
please
um sure so as young said we have a
variety of like
problems in
prime video um so
anything from computer vision to
defender systems nlp
you name it
so what i'm looking for a candidate is
actually
the interest in the space and the
problems that we have so
being interested to work with
recommender system problems and like
solve the
this specific problem for the users
being motivated by the customer data and
improving the customer experience i
think it's it's a big plus
on top of that
kind of
general
thing that i'm looking for is
the critical thinking so how to solve
a big problem and how to kind of break
it down to smaller
blocks and how to how to tackle that
and in the end
i would add that
curiosity is another factor that um it
would be very
um uh very desirable in a scientist
someone who asked questions who dives
deep and like tries to find uh
all the uh different um things that are
uh
that are relevant to the problem and
tackles uh different problems um i would
say these three things
are definitely standing out apart from
um whole things that everyone else
mentioned
awesome ollie uh and then karen i would
love to hear from you
yeah um
my colleagues already give a very
comprehensive list um
i think maybe i just have one thing to
add on top of that
uh that is based on my own experience i
think the team uh collaboration is also
very important here because uh no matter
what model we
you you will work on you you will work
very closely with your upstream and
downstream like a product team
engineering team
so it will make your career more
successful if you have a good team a
collaboration spirit
and lastly of course if you join prime
video i hope you also like to stream
movie and tv so
we'll make your job more enjoyable
it's definitely a perk and it's good to
be passionate about the space i agree
um thank you all so much for answering
those pre-submitted questions i really
appreciate it um up next we're gonna go
to all of our live questions
for everybody that's viewing please just
know we're going to do our best to get
through all of these questions if a
question does require us require us to
share something confidential though we
will have to skip that question so just
bear with us as we're starting to go
through and i'm reading into these
questions that we have right now
we had a question in regards to some of
the difference in roles
um i wanted to understand a little bit
more about what the different roles look
like for example how would you look at a
principal scientist and how would that
differ from let's say a senior applied
scientists i'm not sure
who does anybody want to take that
i i guess excuse me i guess i can i can
take a thing at it and then other folks
can join in so
let's take a step back
you know uh
we can talk about the differences
between principal or senior applied
scientists a little bit but um
essentially the way uh different roles
are defined is based on their their
scope and um and the influence that uh
we are looking for them to have within a
team or an org
etc so
also these definitions are not
necessarily set in stone they vary a
little bit across different orgs but
essentially uh you know
directionally at least they're pretty
consistent across amazon um so
you know
going to the specifics of this question
uh difference between principal and
senior applied scientist it's more about
the scope so the so this
to the scope at which the senior applied
scientist is required to operate um is
is you know is a certain level
and then a principal applied scientist
is supposed to uh perform and and
influence uh you know multiple senior uh
scientists and then uh lastly a senior
principal like jung jun
is you know required to influence pretty
much across the or so just uh you know
the the radius of influence is higher
um from a technological perspective also
uh
that reflects into the the type of uh
stuff that you end up spending most of
your time at so generally a senior
applied scientist and karen can keep me
honest here um you know would would
get the opportunity to dive deeper into
the details a little bit more
then generally a principal applied
scientist especially if it's me
who would you know like
need to be at a slightly higher level of
detail just because you know the breadth
needs to be higher
although that said there are occasions
where uh the more senior folks like
principal or senior principals are
required to really dive down into very
nitty-gritty details for very critical
projects which are like a step function
which can make a step function
difference um also the impact is from a
mentorship score perspective again um
generally at a senior level we expect
our scientists to to mentor uh folks who
are within their team or you know at a
direct level perhaps but at a principle
and even more senior principal level
you're required to actually develop more
processes that are they can stand the
test of time a little bit more that can
have a little bit more a broader and
resounding impact when it comes to
mentorship so usually that requires
scaling through processes um so those
are some of the thoughts that come to my
mind i'd like to open it up to other
folks to to add their thoughts and
especially
you know yeah everybody please correct
me as needed yeah
yeah
thank you rafee i think you're
absolutely right um i agree with what
you just talked about um i totally agree
that sometimes the the boundary of
senior applied scientists and principal
applied centers or even different roles
in amazon is not that um
clear like clear bonded right and
the good thing is it leaves a lot of
flexibility for for us to
reach out and extend
our existing responsibility which is
very good
i'm talking about a senior appliance
scientist which i am i feel like my work
is very hands-on like i get to um work
with data
every day and uh which i like a lot and
um
so as roughly mentioned a lot of
hands-on and i think um i make a lot of
impact within ogg um for example versus
principal applied scientists they are
more they they will they need to they
are looked up so that they can make
impact across ox
um
i actually have been working with rafee
on a couple projects and i do see rafe
hands on a lot as well so um this is
just some general guideline but
in terms of um specific project there's
no such clear-cut
lines at all
so ravi and karen presented lots of
insight inside for details so add a bit
more pretty short so there are always
ability to grow given the growth of
prime video for example live stream
experience is scoping an impact on prime
minister business and the customer
experiences so we started live live in
the channels back in 2015 and invest
heavily on live sports back in 2017
after that it's really exponential
growth in the past five years so the
scope and the impact for someone to join
may change as time goes by for example
now i have seen a couple of senior prize
scientists or video specialists joined
back in
2015-2016 and their scope and impact
increase incrementally and obviously
they have opportunity to grow and soon
they become principal
applied scientists or video specialists
that's a the level of growth and
opportunities in prime video
thank you so much youngjun um and i
would just say from you know somebody
that is constantly hiring for these
roles and seeing our team work i i
wouldn't necessarily once you're part of
amazon we're not necessarily title
centric i think a lot of it has to do
with the work
the impact so i would say if there's a
role that you're interested in you know
look at the title but really be sure to
have a conversation with a hiring
manager somebody from the team the
recruiter to learn more about what the
role is truly doing and what your impact
is going to be
and that'll help drive your decision on
you know if you're interested or not
um
up next you guys we have this question
is a little broad so let's kind of see
how we want to dive in here and tell me
if we do need to skip it but the
question is i'm curious to learn about
all the different titles you have
um i can take a crack at it so um from
the
um so amazon actually um offers one of
the probably most diverse
kind of content
uh across all streaming services and i
can talk about a few of them and i let
others chime in
for the rest so one of the biggest
catalog
content that we have is prime movies and
prime
shows that
they're free for for prime users to
watch another one is
the the
catalog that the customers can can rent
or buy
and that is actually a huge catalog of
of a lot of
older and newer titles that come into
the system
and lastly i want to mention the ad
supported
content which is imdb tv
which is a lot of great movies
titles which are supported with some ads
and are free for the users to watch
thank you for that ali we really
appreciate that insight
um and as i said i'm gonna ask some
questions so for whatever reason if we
can't answer them you all please let me
know um this is an interesting one
actually as a viewer how can i impact
recommendations and personalization
um yeah i can i can go again and let the
others uh continue since i work in
recommendation space um so i would say
that the biggest factor uh that would
drive you recommend your whatever you
see on private video is your watch
history
um
and content that you interact with so
those are the biggest uh
drivers of our content that is shown to
the viewer viewers so the more you
stream uh the more we know what you like
and the more uh you will impact the
recommendations that you would see
yeah i um i totally agree with what ali
just mentioned um and
on top of that i think as a viewer you
can also
impact the recommendation by
your reaction to our prior
recommendation to you so for instance um
as you interact with prime video
we will recommend something to you and
whether or not you add it to the watch
list or you stream the title we
recommend afterward that will help help
us to reinforce our recommendation
system on our side so our purpose is our
goal is always to continuously serve
something that we think will better
fit your uh streaming taste
in addition and we also
consider like what device you are using
and at the time of the day the day of
the week you stream so all of this
valuable impact
inputs are provided by the viewers and
we will take it and
improve our recommendation system
thank you karen really appreciate um
your
information and just what you're sharing
with some of these questions and all of
you thank you so much for these details
uh rafae i feel like this next one is a
good question for you to kick off um
what do you feel are some of the biggest
differences in researching an industry
where there's emphasis on customer
experience versus researching in
academia
sure can we happy to have your answers
so um yeah i think that at least from a
computer vision and machine learning
perspective i feel like
both
academia and industrial research have
value um and i think that they
work
basically
you know they complement each other in
in many ways and over the last decade or
so i would argue
the the the sales between academia or
like academic research what is what used
to be called as academic research and
industry research is is sort of you know
getting overlapped with each other and
you you can you can see that happening
on both ends of the spectrum so i'll
give you one example right for example
even though amazon is very industrial
customer uh obsessed place we still have
many amazon scholars and you know we we
have
a lot of interaction i mean youngjun
mentioned
uh
some interactions with some of the top
universities in the world um so i would
say that the the differentiation is not
that clear cutting anymore and i would
expect it to become even less in the
next
prediction but i think that said the
most important difference that i have
noticed uh when it comes to you know a
place like amazon versus academic
research places is that uh we are
absolutely uh customer obsessed right so
what that means is that the you know the
problems that we pick
all the way to working backwards from
that problem uh all the way to you know
the
we expect to kind of deliver on that on
that problem as far as the the iterative
aspect of it uh they all are driven by
the customer obsession uh so i think
that is the biggest uh difference that i
have noticed and the the way that it
reflects in my opinion
uh in real world and like in our
day-to-day life is in my opinion the
efficiency with which you can actually
uh make
the problem is much in my in general
it's higher in a place like amazon like
then compared to academia
so could you guys hear me i'm not sure
if i think my signal broke in the middle
we had a little bit of break but we were
able to get you back
so no worries we did hear you yeah it
was just a couple quick little blips no
no worries you're good to go um anybody
else want to give some insight into that
question
so i can add some uh some some more
details on proper face insightful
explanations
so it is true you know prime video
actually starting the research programs
with universities actually we identify
the
challenging issues from our deployment
customer facing and then work with
universities academic research so it is
really true that we have overlapping
interest between academic research from
professors and prime videos business
interests and
we are always always working backwards
from customers finding the pain points
and then define a scope of research
together with professors research
institutes and then define some contract
with them so we may or may not know that
we have multiple research contracts from
going at the same time with different
universities and we have seen greater
return of investment in the past several
years so
that's ongoing efforts for prime video
wonderful youngjun thank you
um where the questions are rolling in
everybody so i think we're gonna take
maybe one maybe two more we'll see how
far we get um this question is
interesting uh what technology or trend
in the industry are you most interested
in regardless of work related or not
do i have any takers
it's a broad question
i get data thing um
um what uh
what trends and technology are are we
looking out for most
yeah regardless if it's work related for
prime video um what are you most
interested in or what's the most
exciting to you within the science
community ah got you got you yeah i have
plenty so i will just mention two uh i
do think that these two
uh are to watch out for um
and i'm talking about it not just from a
prime video perspective but in general
one is one is more on the server side
and the other is on the edge edge side
of it uh i i mentioned this like i think
uh
we are we are at a at an inflection
point here in deep learning where
our traditional models have been
extremely label hungry and you know
given the size the rate at which the
data is exploding by keeping up with
that label demand with the traditional
ways in which we've been training models
it's just not something that that is
feasible practically it's just not
feasible and so the latest trend in
using semi-supervised self-supervised uh
type of learning
approaches at using very very large
scales of data um is a is a big trend to
watch out for i i i think that is going
to change things uh quite fundamentally
and the second one is is the edge bit
right um i think that
especially uh you know anything that has
serious network latency issues uh or
very strong interactivity you can talk
think about biological models or even
some of our use cases where you know we
you know because we have a global
audience
we have to overcome these types of
network bottlenecks etc so i think that
moving the compute that the model
requires towards the edge uh whether it
is a intermediate point or an actual
device itself is going to be a
game-changing thing um so yeah those are
i mean there are many others
you know privacy security etc but those
are the two things that i personally am
very interested in
thank you rafae
um we are getting close to time
everybody i have a question but it could
be one that we dive into so ali i'm
going to ask this of you
and see
if how we're able to answer this i know
that we're getting to time for the event
um this sounds more kind of like um
getting an idea of the responsibility of
roles so
a viewer asked what is approximately the
percentage across some of the main
responsibilities such as developing
researching managing